the beast from the east
is back and with it have come plunging
temperatures and heavy snowfall
in woodbridge in suffolk alistair shaw
was the last person to get his covid
vaccine
before the doors shut due to the weather
i was due in this afternoon at 4 30
and i just took the risk because the
weather was getting so bad
that i thought well right that's it i'm
coming in
others arrived for their jabs not
knowing the center had closed
um well there's this country all the
time and it don't matter you know that's
just how it is i can't you know i'm not
worried about it i'm retired so i can
come down
whenever i like i'm not really bothered
i'm a bit disappointed well a lot
disappointed that they didn't send a
text
because that's pretty easy isn't it to
everyone
storm darcy has left fast swathes of the
east and southeast of england beneath a
blanket of snow
as the met office extended its amber
weather warning for the area to monday
afternoon
and it's not just snow to worry about
near
gale force gusts turning the sea at
felixstowe wild
it's strong biting winds from russia and
eastern europe that have caused
temperatures to plummet
making it feel like -9 or 10 but it's
not expected to improve until later in
the week
a yellow weather warning for snow is in
place for the entire
eastern flank of the uk for days to come
we don't tend to get really cold
conditions like this very often the last
time was three years ago in 2018 when we
had the beast from the east and
this event this this week is being
called beast from the east part two
so similar conditions to what we had
three years ago
doesn't happen that often it is winter
but it is going to be
exceptionally cold this week with
temperatures not getting much but
freezing during the daytime
in ipswich nine gritters headed out at
the start of a 12-hour shift
to try to keep the county's roads moving
thankfully most drivers had heeded the
warning to stay home
but there were those determined to brave
the blizzards
in lidden and kent sledgers found a
different way to get their daily
exercise
this lockdown i think has been a lot
harder um
because the weather's been lousy whereas
the last lockdown
we had the nice weather kids could get
out in the garden we could go for long
walks because we've got a dog
but this time it's been really hard
because the weather's been miserable
so this isn't miserable this is just
great
while some trains are still running
southern
and south eastern rail services have
faced severe disruption
some of which will stretch into monday
it all makes life hard for those who
still need to head to work
but for those with time to spare it's a
welcome diversion
from the monotony of lockdown emma
virtually sky news suffolk